if I'm not drinking or snorting
something what the [ __ ] do I actually
enjoy doing you know who am I Africa
Brooke is a speaker a podcast host and
she's helped hundreds of thousands of
people see the world in a new light
Africa does not give a [ __ ] and that's
why I love her if you're on the left
then you're the good person if you're on
the right then you're the bad person
we're hanging out online where these
platforms incentivize binary thinking
are you with us or are you against us
there's only so much you can take most
people didn't like when I said that as a
black person I'm not oppressed that
there is a very real difference between
being a victim and making victimhood an
identity because if you don't think that
you're worthy that's always going to be
the belief that you feed every single
time what became your dark side
from the age of 14 I was a blackout
Drinker that's when I started to see
that I was behaving in the exact same
way that my dad did
sex and sexuality can you talk to me
about what you've learned about those
topics that might benefit me well
without further Ado I'm Stephen Bartlett
and this is the diver CEO I hope
nobody's listening but if you are then
please keep this to yourself Africa
[Music]
let's I mean if you've seen this podcast
before it's no surprise where I'm going
to start but um I was reading about your
story I was reading about
um where you grew up and yes where
you're originally born
give me your earliest most relevant
context give me the context of
um
where you came from and and how that
context shape the person that sits here
with me today oh that's good
some Zimbabwean
I'm from Zimbabwe and I think uh this
accent always falls people into thinking
that I was born and raised here but I
was born in Zimbabwe which is in the
south of Africa and I came to the UK
when I was nine years old so I remember
my life back home in Zimbabwe quite
clearly and vividly actually I don't
remember it being hard apart from my
experiences with my father
even though he could be the most
Charming Man and he was such a beautiful
man he was the kind of person that walks
into a room and you can feel that
Maxwell has arrived just a very
beautiful spirit but when he was drunk
he could be very different completely
different so I think the times that I
can remember experiencing
most of my sadness or frustration as a
child was experiencing that side of my
father because he could be very abusive
and he was physically abusive to my mum
and to myself and my siblings but I
don't even look at those things and
think that I had a horrible childhood in
Zimbabwe I have so many wonderful
wonderful memories of being home and I
still call it home you know when people
ask me where I'm from I always say
Zimbabwe before I say the UK or that I'm
British
um yeah
you know when you say that you look back
on Zimbabwe with fun fun memories yeah
um is that because at the time when in
your household you didn't understand
that behavior you didn't understand that
it was bad behavior or that it was
abnormal
or is it genuinely because on balance
you you consider it to be a
a happy childhood yeah I think it's
actually the letter I think I definitely
understood that this wasn't right
although to be honest there were a lot
of behaviors that my father exhibited
that were considered normal just because
of the culture for example things like
disciplining your wife through hitting
her etc etc or your children it was just
kind of seen as normal
but I definitely knew that it wasn't
right I definitely knew that there was a
problem I knew that seeing a person that
is that drunk was not something that
felt comfortable it wasn't remotely
normal I'm able to now I think an
adulthood hold multiple truths which is
something interestingly enough that I
speak about a lot of my work the
importance of being able to hold
multiple truths because like I say about
my dad
I saw him as a bad person I saw him as
an evil person even and he passed away
in 2004 and I never mourned his death
because of the resentment that I was
holding towards him but then when I got
sober years later I had to hold multiple
truths about him to realize that he was
a beautiful man I got to experience him
in the very early years of my life as
being a very present father
um as being a very loving father before
alcohol came into his life in the way
that it did so I had to then start
holding multiple truths about him
because it wasn't all bad so I think I
hold those fond memories because I've
had to realize that they did actually
exist Beyond everything else
you said in your 10 years you started to
realize that he'd been
um
how bad he'd been to your your mother
yeah
how did you start to realize that at
that age
three stories
um
through speaking to my siblings about
what we had all experienced in the home
because we never really spoke I I don't
know what it's like in your family or
when you were growing up but we never
really spoke
about much especially when it came to
things that were potentially
hard to talk about things that it
revolved around emotions and being
vulnerable things that had anything to
do with intimacy or a lack of intimacy
even the most obvious things like seeing
my mum being hit and not talking about
it almost just pretending that it didn't
happen so I think in adulthood when I
started seeing how other families were
when I started to see how open other
people are I then started to see the
lack in what I had experienced growing
up so I think that's when I started kind
of one I wanted to know more did anyone
else see what was happening did my aunts
and uncles know what was happening
um why didn't anyone talk about it why
didn't anyone talk to us why so I think
I had so many
why type of questions which fueled a lot
of my resentment
yeah
some of the times you used there you
said before alcohol showed up in his
life
as you'll know
um
these things tend to We tend to attract
these things into our lives easily as
you describe it as a a firmer lid to
hold some trauma I think there's some
terminology used previously
um in some some of your work yeah did
you ever understand the trauma that he
was trying to
and bottle up using alcohol
you know what that's something that is
still unfolding because I think there's
only so far
that
other family members will go in terms of
really telling me and my siblings or
anyone else that wants to know the
reality of what was really going on but
I think he was also from a family where
people didn't really have many
conversations his
younger brother had committed suicide
when he was 26 and
there were other instances of mental
health and that wasn't really spoken
about as well because because culturally
people just didn't talk about these
things so I think there were things that
he was suppressing that I'll never ever
know about so I think I've had to make
peace with the fact that I I won't be
able to get all of the answers as to why
and how I just have to understand what
did happen and what I experienced and
forgive where I can get answers where I
can and also let go of expectations
I had a guest on this podcast called Tim
Grover and he he talked about his early
upbringing he was he ended up being
Michael Jordan's and Kobe Bryant's
trainer and he says that
um our childhood experiences tend to
create our Brilliance but they also
create our dark side and he referred to
it as his dark side he told me about his
dark side yeah um Dark Side can
sometimes mean insecurities it can mean
the
the worst traits or character flaws
within us but
from the experience you had
what became your dark side um
oh that's a fantastic question you know
what I ended up replicating pretty much
the same drinking behavior that my dad
had
from the age of 14 up until 24 when I
finally got sober so a decade long
um I was a blackout Drinker I was a
binge Drinker very specifically I didn't
know when to stop because my intention
was never to stop from the first time
that I drunk it's almost as if something
magical happened I realized that I could
change who I was that I didn't have to
feel insecure anymore that I didn't have
to think about the areas in which I'm
Different the areas in which can lead to
me being abandoned because I'm different
and what I mean specifically by that is
when I came to the UK when I was nine
years old I always say this and I I'll
continue saying it because it was one of
the it's a something that I love her but
it was quite big it was the first time
that I realized that I'm black
I had never Stephen had to think about
it before ever had to think about it but
we moved to Kent when in 2001 when we
first came to the country and in my
school it was probably me and my sister
and one other boy called Curtis we were
the only black kids in the entire school
and I know you've shared your similar
experiences with kind of just seeing
just how much you stand out in an
environment that you have to be in and
we were living in Kent for about three
years and then we moved to London but
the imprint was already made the
insecurity around who I was as a young
black girl when I moved to London it was
completely different because now I was
seen as prissy I was seen as attractive
but that was also very confusing in
itself because I still didn't quite fit
in because now to most of the black
people that I was around I was white
because of the the way that I spoke by
the time I was 14 and I drunk alcohol
for the first time
sort of silenced all of those things I
remember it was in a park with some
friends and
the more that I drunk the more confident
I became or so I thought
um and the more that I just felt at ease
in myself and in my body and with the
people around me even though I didn't
stop binge drinking or blackout drinking
from that moment an imprint had been
made a pattern started to develop that
every time that I drunk from that time
the intention was to get [ __ ] up the
intention was to experience that same
level of comfort and confidence that I
felt that first time and I tried and did
replicate that same pattern
over and over and over and over again
for 10 years
and
that's when I started to see that I was
behaving in the exact same way that my
dad did
so I think that's the sort of shadow
that started to form
lying
that became a habit of yours it did
compulsive lying
what what was
compulsive lying doing for you on a
psychological level what was it what was
it allowing you to escape from or Escape
where to was it allowing you to escape
to
um
it was allowing me to
feel accepted
it was
allowing me to sort of create my own
world because the world that I'd been in
a world where
someone that was supposed to protect me
and my siblings and my family
um did the complete opposite and damaged
our family in a very very very big way I
remember that it did start in Zimbabwe
when I would be at school and I was
quite young maybe even six
probably around six or seven I would go
to school and sort of tell other kids
about my dad and who he was and how
amazing he was and all these things that
he would he would do and parts of it
were true but most of it wasn't most of
it was just me trying to create a
reality that I could live with a reality
that made me feel safe a reality that
made me feel comfortable a reality that
other people could sort of step into for
a moment and think wow that's that's
incredible so therefore it would make me
incredible in some kind of way so I
think I started to get rewarded for that
and then it just became habitual because
any time that I felt like I wasn't
fitting in in the way that I wanted to
or that things were happening within our
home that were just very uncomfortable
and I didn't again have the language for
that it was it was all just feeling
knowing that something is quite wrong I
would then go into a different
environment and just create a story and
I when you was speaking to example I
think he was talking about something
similar in relation to lying where he
was saying kind of embellishing the
truth if you will to kind of create a
story and I resonated with that so much
because I think that's exactly what it
was for me just trying to create a
different world and when alcohol was a
part of that as well it was just even
more explosive and I think there was
something quite addictive about that
being able to create your own reality
and convince other people that that
reality is actually true
um so it would it was definitely a big
part of my drinking something that would
come out it's so interesting because
when you were describing why you lied a
lot of people listen to this and think
well I can't relate because I'm not a
liar yeah but the lens in which I sort
of heard that through is
um pretty much everyone listening to
this is lying for the same reason the
words you used were to create a reality
then you said I would be rewarded for
and I found it better to live in and if
you think about
an Instagram filter yeah yes that's a
that's a form of creating a world where
you feel more comfortable and get more
rewards for even like this the selection
of the the online identity that some
some of us create where we show just the
very best or we try and change how we
look or whatever that is surely a form
of lying to get better rewards and to to
create a world where you feel more
comfortable and safer to live in yes
like you you know and so lying is not
just saying something which is not true
yes it's a morphing of one's identity to
create a safer I guess Identity or story
yeah that the world might reward you for
but in doing so you obviously abandon
yourself exactly so it's like um
another word that comes to mind as we
talk about is is deception right it's a
form of of deception and I think it for
me it was
not even just about deceiving other
people it was deceiving myself so that I
could live with myself better you know
if I see myself through this lens
um but yeah it's very interesting how we
can hear certain words and think no that
doesn't that doesn't resonate with me I
don't do that but then it just shows up
very subtly in the things we do every
single day but yeah lying was a was a
huge thing was a huge huge thing for me
and it's something that I really had to
look dead in the eye when I got sober
six years ago
um
yeah
going back to that that period where you
were drinking yeah you were engaging in
certain abandonment star behaviors to
try and escape from you know this
um who you were what is the cost of
abandoning yourself
what is the cost I know it's quite a
profound thing but yeah what was the
cost for you of that continual for
almost 10 years finding ways to abandon
yourself
the cost was that
forgot to know myself
I never got to know myself not in the
ways that I really wanted to anyway I
got I got to know the version of me that
I thought people wanted so I wasted a
lot of time doing that and there was
also a very real mental cost because
waking up next to someone not knowing
where you are not knowing if you've had
sex with that person there's a huge
mental cost to that on your self-esteem
it feels a lot of Shame if he was a lot
of guilt because I would be in
relationships sometimes when these
things would happen not not have I
cheated on my partner or was this just
something innocent because my clothes
are still on so it it really really had
a huge mental cost so there was a lot of
anxiety there was a lot of insecurity I
would even say you know a low level
paranoia because when you wake up not
knowing whether you've done something
but feeling like you will need to
apologize for something
um going through my phone just to have
an idea of what I've done or what I
didn't do who was I with how did I end
up all the way in [ __ ] sorry when I
was in SoHo not too long ago
um
so there was a huge mental cost but also
there was a spiritual cost because just
like I said right a few moments ago not
getting to know yourself
and then getting sober further down the
line and feeling like you're a newborn
baby I I didn't even know what I like to
do what the [ __ ] do I actually enjoy
doing if I'm not drinking or smoking
something or snorting something what do
I actually what do I enjoy you know who
am I as an individual without all of
those things can I even be by myself
so there was a huge spiritual cost and
once I realized the cost of all of those
things it was around the same time that
I discovered the concept of
self-sabotage right when you get in your
own way and that helped me so much just
to even have that language to understand
what this thing actually was why I had
been in that destructive cycle for such
a long time
um I want to just on that point of the
destructive cycle because when you were
explaining waking up you know um the
next day somewhere you don't know you
don't know what you've done the night
before yeah and that giving you guilt to
hurting your self-worth it's yeah it was
my brain was going well this was meant
to be the the medicine for a lack of
self-worth yes and it ends up taking
even more of your self-where so it's
this kind of race to the bottom of your
self-esteem by thinking that the
medication is this kind of destructive
abandonment behavior and it's and that's
weirdly self-reinforcing so you do it to
try and Escape but it harms you so much
that you need that maybe that sort of
surface level attention the alcohol even
more so that leads you in the same place
and that vicious cycle to the bottom of
your self-esteem right and trying to
pick yourself up out of that is
one hell of a task oh yeah it's probably
one of the most grueling things I've
done which is why I actually I'm
actually very grateful for all of those
times that I did Relapse because I think
I was reminded every single time just
how much I wanted to break this [ __ ]
cycle and how much I had to because it's
so
anything that is familiar
anything that is familiar feels safe in
some way even though objectively it
might look like how is this person not
changing their life clearly they're
losing everyone around them and I'm
talking about myself losing everyone
around them can't even stay in any job
for longer than a month unable to commit
to anything incredibly unreliable
how can they not see that something
needs to change but the thing is when
you are in that cycle of
self-destruction self-sabotage if it
feels familiar it's kind of all you know
that when I would have those bursts of
sobriety where I'd be sober for three
months and six months and I didn't have
any chaos I didn't have any drama I was
reliable I people were saying that
they're proud of me you know I could see
that I was doing well it made me
uncomfortable
it made me uncomfortable because it
didn't feel familiar and there was
always this thing in the back of my mind
that would sort of say you're gonna [ __ ]
up anyway so might as well just
might as well just do it now you know
and that's when the justifications would
come things like I haven't had a drink
in six months so maybe if I just have
one it's it's going to be different you
know or I would say things like um
I have a problem with alcohol but
cocaine is not the problem so maybe I
can still have a line every now and
again and then you know and then I can
still be with my friends and so all of
these justifications but when I really
looked at it I was uncomfortable with my
life actually being drama free chaos
free and being reliable being able to be
there for the people that I that I love
um because I was just so comfortable in
that destruction and I chose that every
single time until until I didn't until I
couldn't
if someone's listening to this
um and they're in one of those sort of
downward
um negatively reinforcing self-esteem
Cycles yeah where you're carrying out a
behavior because it because you have low
self-esteem but then that behavior is
actually resulting in a lowering of your
self-esteem it can be a toxic
relationship where you're staying
because they took your self-esteem so
you think that they're the only ones
that can give it back but they're
hurting you even more yeah I see that a
lot in my DMs right it can be other what
advice would you give to someone to try
and break out of that
um that negatively reinforcing
self-esteem cycle um I think one of the
things I think questions are always the
best place to start I always like to
think of self-sabotage and
self-destruction as self-protection
you're actually protecting yourself from
something and a lot of it is unconscious
you're not consciously deciding to get
in your own way you're not consciously
deciding to stay in chaos and drama
because you just absolutely love it
maybe for some people that might be the
case but for most of us it's entirely
unconscious but I think
getting clear on what the benefits are
because you're getting some kind of
reward from it right because if you
don't think that you're worthy if you
don't think that you're lovable that's
always going to be the belief that you
feed every single time it's some kind of
confirmation it's like a c i I see I
said that I wasn't unlovable that's why
I choose someone who shouts at me that's
why I choose someone who manipulates me
that's why I choose someone who cheats
on me over and over again that's why I
choose someone who shames me or whatever
the details might be so I think there's
always some kind of reward that we're
getting from that situation and I think
it can be a very sounds quite abstract
but I think it can be an important
question to ask yourself what am I what
reward am I actually getting from this
and is this going to be worth it in the
long term
and all of this to me kind of sounds
like shifting your identity and what
you're used to and allowing yourself to
get used to things that might not be
familiar yet I think you also have to
understand that when you're breaking
some kind of cycle it's going to be
uncomfortable that's why I'm a huge
advocate for discomfort because I think
a lot of us when we change a pattern the
moment we feel uncomfortable even though
it's good for us the moment we feel
uncomfortable we'll pull the plug and we
often pull the plugs so prematurely so I
think one of the things that I would
suggest and I say this to my clients and
anyone that I speak to allow yourself to
be in that discomfort because a lot of
the time it's where you currently are
with your identity and the identity that
you're trying to step into someone who
is more lovable for example but that
middle part is going to be quite
uncomfortable and you just have to stay
there while things sort of reconfigure
is that like because you're contending
against two counters or counters yes yes
and it takes time to believe a new story
so you're gonna have to sit in maybe a
feeling of him
feeling like a bit of an imposter or you
know what I mean it's almost like this
evidence but right at the end of the day
all these stories are backed by either
true or false but it's subjective
evidence yeah that's who you are and
what the world thinks of me and what I'm
capable of so that's it writing new
evidence is not an easy or a quick no no
and it's not supposed to be because I
think
um I think we also have this idea that
it's supposed to be easy you know that
kind of once you make a decision and you
decide that you're going to do it that
it should just work and if it doesn't if
it's uncomfortable that means it's wrong
that means you should pull the plug
that's not that's not always the case
what she what do you still
self-sabotage
with or how do you still sabotage
you know what it is for me romantic
relationships
and it always helps me when I'm very
honest about the fact that this is an
area where I still have self-sabotaging
Tendencies so what that looks like is
feeling
when someone is trying to get close to
me
I will immediately start to feel
suffocated
I'll start to feel like I need to find
something wrong with you so that you
don't get too close even if I want you
to get close but it's because there's a
a part of me doesn't want to be
vulnerable because vulnerability in that
area means being exposed it means being
raw exposed to what exposed
vulnerable
you know what I think it is I think it's
a to put it very simply I think it's
it's a feeling of if you really get to
know me you might abandon me and I think
this is not something that's even you
know on a conscious level because I have
a strong sense of self I know who I am
etc etc but I think there is
still those sort of traces from
childhood from everything that I've
experienced in my life that those
remnants of that that have that voice
that say if I really let you in and you
actually get to know me you might
abandon me so what I need to do I need
to find a way to get in there first and
abandon you before you abandon me
so that might look like as I said once
the person is starting to kind of get
close I will feel suffocated I'll feel
like okay it's getting too much I need
my own space what's what's wrong with
you danger yeah huh danger
um where did you learn that model that a
romantic relationship might be danger oh
gosh I mean take a guess take a guess
the the
first relationship that I ever saw a man
and woman a couple being together was my
mother and my father and that's the
model in which I had to kind of build my
own idea of romantic love and what
relationships look like so I've never
wanted to get too close and I could
never have said this to you before I
didn't have language for it but when I
looked at the patterns from relationship
to relationship I always thought that
they had a timeline as well never going
anywhere beyond the one year mark always
feeling like okay that's enough we've
done our time let's let's uh release
yeah yes so I think um romantic
relationships is one and I also had one
in terms of money and this one I really
had to nip it in the bud when I started
my consulting firm five years ago
I used to sabotage any opportunity to
potentially make more money than my mum
so my mum is a nurse
so when I started sharing my sobriety
story and I started realizing that I'm
actually very good at what I do in terms
of speaking in terms of supporting
people I'm a very curious person and I
do have a powerful story a powerful
story that allows me to reach so many
different types of people so it gained a
lot of traction quite early on in 2016
2017.
so I would start getting speaking
opportunities in the beginning
everything was sort of free and I was
okay with that never had to negotiate
things around money money was not
something that was spoken about in my
family growing up I don't know what it
was like for you but the only time that
money conversations were really had
um was through arguments you would only
hear Money spoken about where there
wasn't enough money
etc etc etc so I always had so many
different money stories money is very
hard to come by money doesn't grow on
trees you have to work hard for money
um so many ideas about rich people rich
people are bad rich people are this and
no one in my family explicitly said that
but I think culturally it was sort of
just a thing people don't have to
explicitly say it culturally we all know
what the stories are so when I would
hear or get emails saying Africa we'd
love for you to speak at this thing it's
just half an hour what is your rate
we're offering 3K
um I would just experience so much
discomfort knowing that my mum is
working
so many hours as a nurse on her feet and
she's probably making half of that or
just about that
so what I would do and this was not a
conscious thing until I started looking
at my money story I would let those
emails sit any email that was saying I
would be getting paid
I would let those emails sit until it
was too late they've probably offered
someone else because I just felt so
uncomfortable making money so easily so
I would sabotage any opportunity to get
paid but if it was free I will reply
straight away I'll do it but when you're
in business that doesn't [ __ ] work
it doesn't work but even outside of that
I I was shown that because I was
incapable of receiving when it came to
money I was incapable of receiving in so
many areas I was incapable of receiving
love fully because when I did I would
shut down because a part of me thinks I
don't deserve it I was then capable of
receiving opportunities because I'd feel
like this has happened way too easily
I'm supposed to it's supposed to be hard
but this is so easy so I would be
suspicious of it and sabotage it so
those are the two main areas that I've
really had to do some work on over the
past years on the first point
um you were very much preaching to the
choir there as I've talked about quite a
few times on this podcast why do I see
relationships as like a bird trapped in
a cage or someone trapped in jail well
okay well that's what my father was my
father was trapped my father my whole
life I I was convinced he was trapped
that was my first model of what a
romantic relationship was so of course
it was the most
um most evidence-backed yeah and so
you've got a it's similar to what we
were talking about earlier about like
stepping into a new story yes and
although every part of your being is
going this is bad you've got to stay you
do communicate with in this case the
person say by the way this this happens
so yes I struggle yes
um and hopefully build new evidence and
the right person can help you build new
evidence I agree which is what my
girlfriend helped me to do she helped me
to build without by just being herself
and not being a prison guard
she created new evidence and that new
evidence is strong it's not the old
evidence is still there I don't actually
think the old evidence will ever go oh I
love that you say that Stephen I really
do because I think it's again this idea
that it has to go completely before we
step into the other one and I think
that's what holds people back from fully
stepping into their new identity because
they think
if I'm really supposed to be here and
this is actually real and I have all of
this new evidence that's not supposed to
be there at all and I think again
there's multiple truths they can coexist
it's just what you choose to feed over
and over again
yeah and you you know if you think of
spiders like I'm not scared of spiders
but there's a part of me that goes
there's a lot of evidence because I've
seen other people running away from them
I've seen films yes but I'm not I know
like objective but I've got enough
evidence to say that despite they don't
even bite yeah you know no one's dying
of spiders really but I'm still there's
still a little bit of evidence be
careful you know and I can exist with
those two truths as you as you described
it you're totally right though in the
sense that people expect them that they
will get to a place where they are
healed and cured completely
and I I just have never seen it me
neither me neither never seen it ever
and I think we have a current culture
actually so I'm um
I'm a coach and consultant and speaker
Etc who's in the realm of self-help
but despises
the self-help industry for a multitude
of reasons because I think it
perpetuates that idea that idea of
healing as if it's a destination yeah
you know you sign up for this course get
this book listen to this podcast and
then it's it's done then you're healed
so I think there's a lot of people that
are in a very good place if you were to
look at it in a very holistic way but
continuously believe that they have to
rid themselves of these very human
things and this you know inevitable
human discomfort that we all experience
and they put labels on it to make it you
know mean like it's this
um so yeah I think there's a cult there
is a culture right now where people are
on this continuous journey of healing
when actually some of these things won't
actually
go away completely and that's fine
that's normal it's an interesting thing
because there are some people out there
as well I want to get your take on this
sure I've basically made healing their
identity uh-huh it's their personal
brand it's their space being broken and
healing is there it's who they are and
they've embraced that is that harmful
and dangerous in your view absolutely I
think it is I think it is because it's
it again perpetuates another idea which
ties into this that
we need to be on this pursuit of
constantly fixing something you know
um and I think I've also seen people do
that in the as you say it as a brand but
people making it yeah making it the
actual business their public Persona
this is who I am and I think it
encourages other people or makes other
people feel that they need to do the
same thing or that they need to sort of
make their pain their identity as well
you also see this with people
um who uh contrarian just for the sake
of being contrarian right I think that's
why you yeah they just have to disagree
they just have to disagree with you and
they usually that's why when I talk
about
um you know this kind of
seemingly a battle between the work
versus anti-work I always
see that essentially they're quite the
same they're exactly the same you will
have the people that are for example
anti-work want to be contrarian for the
sake of it you know screaming about how
woke everyone has got if people are
let's say talking about being inclusive
they'll just label that as work it's the
exact same behavior as they claim to
oppose which I find very interesting how
people can be so
loud about something and be so convicted
and be wanting to point out a specific
type of behavior not realizing that
they're behaving in the exact same way
but I think it is part of that
performance where people are being
rewarded because they're performing in a
very specific way and they see that okay
if I perform in this way I'm going to
get likes I'm going to get opportunities
I get to to sort of feel it really feeds
the ego as well when you have your Echo
chamber and you have people that say yes
to everything you have people that see
you as some sort of um leader but I
think it's building some very
interesting characters online especially
I wonder if both extremes so the far
left and the far right I wonder if
they're just both low self-esteem yes
yes because they're the ones that seem
to need the the reinforcements yes I
will be militant about these views
because by being further over here I'm
getting more people that are clapping
yes you know whereas Nuance seems to be
a place where you don't care much as as
much about the Clapping yeah you're not
really doing it for the clap you're
doing it for in my view more for truth
yes yes I I see that a lot and have you
found
um
would you say I think from listening to
everything you've said I I kind of have
an idea of what this would look like for
you but would you say that you're more
in that Nuance would you say you've
always been more in the middle or have
you ever found yourself on either I used
to think I was ever on the left yeah now
if I think I'm somewhere in the middle
yeah so um I can't what you described
earlier is like an intolerance of ideas
it's
you know and both but both extreme side
so the far left the far right are both
just really intolerant yeah and I and
they're not willing to have a
conversation with anybody so I find
myself being pushed more towards this
center point where I find people like me
people like you yeah I think I don't
know where you consider yourself yeah
the exact same you know what I don't
think I've ever
um
even used language like I'm on the left
or anything like that and maybe there's
something about being an immigrant
because when I speak to immigrants and
people that are not from this country I
think we have a different relationship
with politics in general you will never
really hear most people
um saying that on the left or they're on
the right I think it won't really happen
most people are the majority of people
really are in that Center in that middle
ground I would say if you were to look
at my values and what I stand for
objectively yes I'm a left-leaning
person but I don't make that my identity
I don't look at everything on that side
and say okay check check I agree with
that everything is context dependent and
there are many things that I agree with
from different sides because I just look
at what is the context what are we
talking about does this make sense to me
is this applicable in real life
um so that's the sort of
process that I take myself through and
it's neither left or right it's very
much in the middle like everyone like
the majority of people
yeah I think the majority of people
probably are but but it I think
especially in this day and age it takes
it's much probably easier because you
get to fit in if you're on either side
yes there's no Club in the middle yeah
there's no you know what I mean there's
no uniform yeah in the middle so you
don't you don't those that might want to
fit in and be reinforced by um a group
aren't going to find that in the middle
ground yeah pick a side do you actually
see what I mean it's like yeah it's a
club they have you know a uniform they
have stickers they have like a schedule
they have a doctor in they have Ten
Commandments yeah this is why people
join Cults isn't it it's true and you
know what um speaking of Cults when I
wrote when I wrote my open letter
um why I'm leaving the cult of weakness
I
was really trying to have this
conversation because essentially I I was
speaking about what we're talking about
now an invitation into that middle
ground where most people are inviting
people to acknowledge nuance and context
to really realize that black people for
example we don't all think the same we
have very different experiences and we
have very different opinions we have
very different beliefs World Views
most people
um that identify as being on the left
would not have that conversation with me
it's only just starting to happen now
the only people that would be willing to
have those conversations with me would
be people that would be seen as being on
the right and I found that very
interesting that you know when you look
at being a leftist it is about being
tolerant it is about
um well I guess that would be what would
what would that be would it be classic
liberalism if you were to I guess so
right
um but even that approach is seen as
right wing now so I understand why a lot
of people really are getting pushed out
of the left and more into the center
because most people would not have that
conversation with me because the moment
you critique something from the left
you're labeled as being on the right
which is just the most absurd thing I
have ever heard
um but I think now two years on
things are starting to shift a little
bit more I think people have stopped
being so fearful of what is known as
cancer culture even though I prefer to
call it Collective sabotage because I
think that's a much more accurate term
for it I think people are being less
afraid now to ask questions to be like
actually let's let's hear what this view
actually is we don't have to agree with
it but we can at least acknowledge that
it exists but I think people that are on
the right from my own experience
especially if we're talking about media
Etc have been more willing to have these
conversations and to have more debates
and to honor that gray more than the
left
I've you know I've probably had
thousands of tweets from people telling
me that I cannot speak to that person on
my podcast right
thousands of tweets and I promise you
I've never had those tweets from someone
on the right yeah no matter which guest
I get on and what they believe no one
from the right has said Steve you cannot
platform that person right it's never
happened so and that that again you're
not help you're you're
basically going to punish me if I don't
um say think and have conversations that
are in line with your Doctrine yeah and
for me that for me has been alienating
and this is why I now consider myself to
be more in the middle because I don't
agree with that intolerance I think I
should be able to have a conversation
with anyone including Donald Trump right
I I hope I never get to the point where
I would not be willing to have a
conversation conversation you know what
I mean yeah that's a that's a that
reminds me of like the I don't know 18th
century I know nothing about history so
I just named an old Century reminds me
of the 18th century when they used to
like burn books because they even want
people to hear stuff yes and yes anyway
speaking of controversial topics one of
the things that's become surprisingly
controversial over the last couple of
years is and probably for a little while
longer
um since the 17th century
um is this idea of accountability which
to me seems like much of the antidote to
self-sabotage is like taking personal
responsibility for your life and your
situation I've heard you talk about this
I actually think this was the first the
first one of your first videos that
caught my attention was you talking
about taking responsibility in a really
you know a fairly direct way so tell me
how taking responsibility what that
means to you but how that helped you to
rise out of that phase you had from 14
to 24. yeah oh it was huge it was huge
and it had to be one of the first things
that I did actually as I as I think
about this and sort of speak out loud
I think what allowed me to get and stay
sober that eighth and final time was
taking personal responsibility I think
all of the other times I had wanted to
place blame on a lot of things outside
of me so my dad would have been the
easiest person because he was an
alcoholic and because of his abuse and
because of everything we experienced and
because of the instability because of
coming to a new country moving to a part
of the UK where just me my sister and
Curtis are the only black kids the
adversity I experienced from that so I
think there were so many ways that I
could externalize right but I think the
moment that I was able to say okay well
Africa what part did you have to play in
this so you've experienced all of this
adversity what now what [ __ ] now
no one else can do it for you and I
think that helped me so much and another
thing that I had to do which is a part
of that responsibility and
accountability was making amends so
people that have followed the 12-step
program for example will know that
making amends is a huge part of it I
didn't follow the toaster program I
what's the 12-step program so 12-step is
AA essentially Alcoholics Anonymous you
go through a process a 12-step process
of accountability essentially and one of
those steps is making amends reaching
out to the people that you've harmed and
making amends and that's what I had to
do and I I really did that and there was
a lot of Shame there was a lot of guilt
there were a lot of people that didn't
want to hear it but there were a lot of
people that were very grateful that even
after all of these years I'm coming to
them and acknowledging something that I
did or played a part in and only then
could I actually move forward with my
sobriety knowing that I am responsible
yes I've experienced a lot of adversity
but I am the one that gets to decide
what now so fast forward to finding
ourselves in a culture where even just
conversations around personal
responsibility are have been politicized
because I've noticed they're labeled as
right wing the moment isn't that weird
it's mad
isn't that crazy the moment you say
you do realize there is a lot in your
life that you can control you're called
a bigot
[Applause]
I'm a puppet and I'm a victim there's
nothing I can control it's and it's that
political party that did this yeah okay
so yes
and that yeah
it's [ __ ] crazy it's mad and I think
I've
I speak to my family and my friends
about all of these things quite a lot
actually and because I'm still very much
in touch with everyone back home in
Zimbabwe and because I have that
perspective
when I compare to that part of the world
to the Western World it this just seems
like a completely different world like
some kind of show it can't be real that
people can get upset to know that there
are things in your life that you can
control yes you might have experienced X
Y and Z but you are responsible for how
you move forward yes there might be
other components maybe it is the system
maybe it is your familial environment
whatever the details might be but there
are also things within your control the
fact that people can
label that as
being bigoted the moment you say I I
just wouldn't you want that to be the
case wouldn't you want to have things
that you can control the thought of
being powerless yeah to my circumstances
is the most terrifying thing in the
world you know being being a being a big
that's why I refer to it as a puppet
that someone else is pulling these
strings right and I have no I'm
powerless to my situation so I think
it's I find it empowering and liberating
to say do you know there is a lot of
things I can control yes I'm I'm broke
yes I'm in this situation but there are
there's something that I can do yeah and
I have to also Express the Nuance that
you did which is there are a lot of
people that are um that are disabled
there are a lot of people that have
found themselves in terrifically
unfortunate circumstances through no
fault of their own yes but I find it
really important for my sanity of mind
and my optimism for the future to know
that there is something
often there is something that I can do
to change my situation absolutely that's
a controversial idea
imagine that would you have I couldn't
believe the people typing out at you
Rich [ __ ] with his cards what
what what is it though do you do you
think you know what that is yeah because
it holds a mirror up to you it makes you
feel like for some people and I think it
was for me at some point as well holding
that mirror up and saying you know what
I might have had part to play in this
and I'm actually I I can have a part in
getting out of the situation for some
people is it evidence of their
inadequacy that they just don't have the
self-esteem to confront so it's easier
to blame blame is a nice a nice Shield
it's a nice way to deflect the attack
against my already fragile self-esteem I
would do that of course when I was
younger and someone might point at
something blame was a way for you not to
hit me in the self-esteem it was a way
of saying no no no no that's not because
I'm inadequate or because I'm not
capable or I'm not smart or because I'm
not working hard it's because of this
other thing and so leave me alone Africa
blocks yes it's like do you know what I
mean that's that's my analysis a bit
often is it's for some people it's it's
look it's a
it feels like evidence of their
inadequacy yes and why what would
someone not like that well because
it makes you feel like [ __ ] yeah and I I
think because we're also
being encouraged I've especially the
youngest generation who I
really
now more than ever want to make more of
an effort to really speak directly to
them is because I think we're we're sort
of training each other to not prioritize
emotional resilience because along with
personal responsibility resilience is
also another controversial word you know
this this idea that you can build a
strong Foundation within yourself that
even if something happens externally
outside of you you are able to deal with
it you don't have to go into that deep
dark place and think that is that full
stop so I think because most people
are not emotionally resilient and are
not nurturing and sort of cultivating
that within themselves it continues that
cycle where you just end up in perpetual
victimhood and then we are in a culture
that rewards victims you know and I I
think self-correction there actually and
I want to make this very clear that
there is a very real difference between
being a victim someone who has genuinely
been victimized and making victimhood an
identity there's a there's a huge
difference between the two but I think
when you start to make victimhood an
identity for anything and everything
that's when it might be time to actually
hold a mirror up to yourself on that
word resilience yeah I think the reason
why resilience is in part at least why
it's a controversial topic is because it
kind of starts to merge into the lane of
like mental health and resilient people
when they think of resilience they think
of like shut up and deal with it yeah
you know what I mean yeah and then that
that acts as in Conflict to them
Narrative of like express yourself feel
your emotions yeah it's okay to be not
okay yeah so talk to me about the
distinction you make between those two
things and your relationship with both
you know what I guess this is where I
would bring it back around
to holding those multiple truths because
why do we think that we have to choose
between one or the other why can't you
be both emotionally resilient as an
individual as a being and allow yourself
to express yourself and allow yourself
to be vulnerable and allow yourself to
have those real low moments that we all
do and I think both can co-exist it's
really not one or the other so what is
the opposite of resilience then
hmm
the word weakness comes to mind but I
don't know if that's accurate
I don't know if that's accurate to what
I'm not sure
but it's interesting because the word
weakness comes to mind and maybe a part
of me
or even for someone listening we
we think associating the word weak
to yourself means there's something
wrong with you that it's a bad word I
think there's this idea that it's it's
bad to be weak or it's not acceptable to
be weak but I think we all have moments
of weakness but I don't know if that
would be the opposite of
of resilience what do you think
um so if we're talking about emotional
resilience maybe the opposite is
emotional
maybe fragility yeah maybe I don't know
um it's something within that realm
right yeah and the reason I I'm
basically Playing devil's advocate was
myself to see if
to see if it is two truths because or if
what we were describing earlier about
being expressive and being in touch with
your emotions is that being emotionally
fragile or is that something else I
wonder if another word that's coming to
mind if some reason soft
I think it's both possible to be soft
and whatever you would consider hard
because just in very simple language
when I hear the word resilience you have
to be
hard there's something sort of it's not
necessarily stoic but but it's it's sort
of that kind of language where you're
really fully grounded in yourself your
back is straight you're internally up
you know whereas the other side of that
is maybe maybe there is an element of
fragility which is fine I don't I don't
think it's a bad thing allowing yourself
to be soft allowing yourself to be
um to not be as strong all of the time
so I I think it's interesting thing
because on one hand you're saying be
resilient but then also be the opposite
of resilience yes yeah
yeah it can be context-specific Behavior
so you can be resilient in the sense
that when someone
um pelts abuse at you and your Instagram
DMS you have the resilience to not
internalize that not let it
um destroy your day or your mood and to
move on but then you can be I guess
emotionally you know then your dog might
die I've got a lovely dog running around
somewhere here yeah and my dog might die
and that is real cause for emotional
expression and to be emotionally
to be soft and to be
um open and to feel yes so maybe it's
context specific yeah I think so I think
so but again I I think they can both
coexist
how did you get to this place of
self-awareness because
you know
um I I you know we all know people who
are repeating cycles and they have no
either they're taking their
responsibility for it or they just don't
know that they're doing it yeah and
sometimes as friends and this is again
this is us looking in on this situation
as if we know what's best for them so
there's an error there but we look we
see friends family going through cycles
and they don't know what they're doing
and they don't they don't understand
themselves enough to the point where you
are today where you clearly
um you exhibit High self-awareness and
understanding of yourself your past your
behavior and the causes of it
um one of my favorite quotes that I've
ever written which is based on based on
a friend I had was um you can read as
many books as you like but if you can't
read yourself you'll never truly learn a
thing but you can also say you can read
as many books as you like but if you
can't read yourself you'll never make
progress yes because you can have the
information but implementing it requires
understanding the being in which yeah
you're implementing that too so how did
you become so apparently self-aware
you know what I think
I've always loved to read I've always
loved to read and to to hear other
people's stories and to hear other
people's thoughts so one of the first
people that I discovered
um the eighth time that I got sober was
Carl Jung
so he's a incredible psychotherapist who
explores Shadow work and you know our
Shadow Self Etc and I think through his
work and then finding many other
teachers many other mentors along the
way
um just through books mainly books and
self-study I was able to finally have
language for the things that I was
experiencing internally so I think it
helped that I did have that Foundation
off already being quite a self-aware
person but now having language for my
behavior and I think just through
different practices even
reading something about why you know
lying to yourself is a form of
self-betrayal it meant that every time
that I was in a situation and I could
feel myself about to lie I would kind of
challenge myself to not and to just say
something different or to just say what
I actually mean so I think it's been a
combination of self-study
um reading tuning into the
self-awareness I already had but using
it in just a different way and actually
stepping into the arena and practicing
so I think that that has helped me kind
of developed my sense of self over time
what about writing and writing writing
has always helped but you know what's
interesting I found especially in those
10 years
I would write in my journal as if
someone was going to read it so I would
lie what were you lying about in your
diary
oh that's a good question I was lying
about
how I really felt about my relationship
so I was writing as if my boyfriend at
the time would read it
um
so I wasn't being completely honest
about how unhappy I was
I wasn't being honest about
cheating in our relationship when I was
drunk
um I wasn't being honest about my
relationship with alcohol
I wasn't being honest about how I really
felt about one particular family member
who I really wanted to heal things with
um
but it felt weird because
we we didn't speak about emotional
things in my family so there was a lot
of resistance around medding mending
that relationship even though I knew
exactly what I needed to do
um why do you speak about in past tense
which part by that family member mending
it you speak of it as if it's past tense
what exactly did I say just um you're
referring to it as if you haven't mended
it I haven't
right I haven't and I wrote that entry
it's in the journal that I found the
other day thank you for pointing that
out
um
I haven't it's been seven years since I
wrote that
so maybe now it's bothering you can see
it in your face really yeah
it does it does she was on
that list of amends
that I had to make back in 2016. and I
made amends with everyone on that list
apart from her and I see her quite often
and there'll be times where I feel like
I want to say something because there's
not even anything specific that happened
it's just the way that I was behaving at
the time that I was in the height of my
of my destruction and
she had just moved from Zimbabwe to here
and I was always her favorite cousin and
we were so close and she was so excited
to see me and to see me after all of
these years
and when she came she didn't meet the me
that she remembered
and I noticed that very early on
and now we're much older seven years
later I can still see that there's a
part of her that feels
hot in some way and I know that there's
something that I can do and say to sort
of break that
but I just there's a lot of resistance
around it because in my family
they're just certain conversations we
don't have but I've been starting to
have those conversations with some
family members but she's just the one
person that I haven't done it with yet
why
I think there's almost a fear of the
unknown
of what our relationship will look like
Beyond this and I know we can sound mad
because someone listening to this might
think just have the conversation I'm a
huge advocate for conversations that are
uncomfortable
but when it comes to this for whatever
reason
there's a fear of the unknown even
though I know that the unknown is going
to be
potentially a stronger relationship
so you could say there's always a
an element of self-sabotage when it
comes to this but it's a fear of some
kind of unknown around that
any advice well I I mean I struggle with
the same thing so let's not pretend that
I'm perfect in this Arena but what's
some of the advice that sometimes helps
reframe the decision is you know taking
myself to the to my deathbed and
thinking about the decisions I would if
this was if I was laying there and this
was the last moments of my life would I
what decision would I wish I would have
made on this particular situation yeah
that's quite clarifying and it also it
also cuts out this kind of unconscious
feeling that I think we all have that
there'll always be time to do it yes we
can always do it next year yeah but we
don't live forever unfortunately right
we live under the illusion that we do
that's why there's a sand timer on there
it's just a nice reminder to me that I'm
actually not infinite I'm finally and so
that gives me a little bit of urgency to
make um to live in a less Petty Way in a
more a way that's more aligned with like
my inner truth and my own values so yeah
what would your you know if this were
if you would touch wood diagnosed with
something today and you you said you
know what I'm gonna get my home in order
um
would you have that conversation I would
absolutely have that conversation and
you know what I'm grateful very grateful
that you and I have just had this
exchange because when I found that
journal a few days ago and I saw that
entry saying I need to speak to her
I wrote I'm going to do this this week
and I finished the entry with
if I don't do this I'll never know what
our relationship can be I'm going to do
this this week and it was seven years
ago
I'm gonna [ __ ] do it this week
you're gonna get a message from me
saying
she no longer talks to me she's blocked
me on Instagram
that's what the unknown was about
wow my goodness and you know again what
you've just done
is hold a mirror up to side because I
can feel a sort of tightness in my chest
but I also feel kind of like a relief in
my shoulders at the same time so it
feels quite conflicting but it makes
sense
um
because you've just held a mirror up to
me because in every other area of my
life whether it's business or life or
writing I'm very sure I can have any
type of conversation I'm very assured
and confident and know exactly what I
need to do but it's amazing how in
certain areas there's still that sort of
childlike or I can't I can't do this
it's too much that's too big
that's why having someone even in a
brief exchange that can hold a mirror up
to that part of you and just ask just
one question without asserting or trying
to
put forward a specific thing you should
do
um just a question that can kind of make
you think oh
I hadn't actually thought about that
I mean I've got those things in my life
too so like of course I have I've got
conversations that I just we all we put
off for various reasons and yeah I think
one of the things as well that I that I
often ask myself is like if you get too
tied up in the outcome and it all come
becomes outcome dependent what are they
going to say how's it going to be you
probably never make the decision but if
it becomes based on like
why do I need to do this for myself yeah
irrespective of outcome you know what I
mean then you start living more in your
truth yeah and the second point I was
going to say is that tightness in your
chest it's an interesting thing because
whenever we find ourselves in those
situations where something is making us
uncomfortable or you know you described
as a tightness in the chest yeah the
tightness in the chest is not gonna
um doesn't leave us because we ignore it
it just it it's like this little
Insidious Force inside of us that will
lead us up in little ways and we think
often as I have in my past that if I
just suppress or compartmentalize that
right it will that's the best way to
deal with it I think the way that we
release whatever that tightness and the
tightness in the chest is such a good
indicator it means we've got work to do
right right because think about that
analogy like that conversation didn't
put the tightness in your chest the
tightness was already there yeah the
tension was already there yes you just
it just came to the surface yes
so the way to never have the tightness
again is to release
the the thing the thing the young
addressed yeah
one of the things I've heard you talk
about a lot is your your journey and
your
evolving relationship with sex and
sexuality and how that changed from when
you were very young through the period
when you were drinking a lot
um till today can you talk to me about
that Evolution and what you've learned
about those topics
that might benefit me yes absolutely
so
I'm going to
sort of keep referring to my sobriety in
that period of my life because it was so
transformative
and it revealed so much to me so much
that I could have never imagined at the
time so something that also happened
when I got sober I think this was about
a year into my sobriety
I realized just how much sexual shame I
was holding so much of it and I
initially sort of wanted to fix it
wanted to do something about it what are
some surface level things that I can do
what can I read what can I sort of dive
into how can I deal with it from where I
am now as a 25 year old but I quickly
realized that I actually had to trace it
back to see where it even comes from and
I realized just like so many things it
did come from my childhood being raised
in a Christian home
I learn again not directly more so
indirectly that being a sexual being was
not something that was of God it was not
something that was supposed to be a part
of who I am pleasure was never discussed
sex was never discussed even
Intimacy in general I never saw my
parents hold hands I never saw my
parents hold hands I never saw them kiss
I never saw them hug I never saw any
sort of affection but I knew that they
loved each other I knew that they cared
about each other but affection and
intimacy I just never saw that Not For a
Moment
did you see that growing up
um
it's a really interesting one because
I'd say I'd say yes and no so I say yes
because below the age of maybe eight
maybe I could've got memories of that
and then above the age of 10
um no and I call my parents by their
first names okay I really struggled with
with intimacy because of the exact same
reasons right even the word best friend
made me cringe until the age still kind
of makes me cringe now
like when people would say it or call me
their best friend this is part of me
like Steven meets like it's just a bit
even boyfriend would make me like ah
prison
me too that's why when I found the word
partner I was like okay yeah
stand next to each other we don't
oh my goodness so when I sort of wanted
to really understand where a lot of the
sexual shame was stemming from or just
more so even outside of sex intimacy
intimacy feeling very disconnected to
other people when it came to intimacy
but also from myself
I realized that I could only be
expressive as a sexual being if I was
drunk or if I was high if I was in that
place where of course my inhibitions are
low but I had no insecurities I didn't
have to feel like I'm doing something
wrong I didn't have to feel like my
pleasure was wrong but then when I got
sober all of those things came to the
surface and then I I had to look that in
the eye so that also became something
that I started sharing over time as well
as sort of sharing my journey with
sobriety I then started sharing the
things that were revealed as a byproduct
of me getting sober and sexual shame was
a huge one was a big part of that my
relationship with sex has evolved a lot
yeah over over time I think it was early
in my early years influenced by porn yes
for many people so me too that's the way
I went into the game in trying to be
those those male porn stars right
and I think over time and I think
there's this wider issue in our society
specifically I've got to be honest with
men yes
um
what they think that what they think sex
is in terms of this kind of
very aggressive often dominating
transactional
um encounter yeah and then there's you
know again I'm just I'm just talking
freely I don't give a [ __ ] whatever
please do please but I'm seeing a lot in
my in my close friends they're all in
relate they're often in relationships
not all of them where they're having
problems with
their sexual relationship with their
partner they're basically saying things
to me and I'd say this is crazy I'd say
75 to 80 of my male friends are saying
my partner doesn't want to have sex she
doesn't like having sex yeah and I was
there at one point too my partner said
that to me at 1.2 yeah and I took it on
face value I thought they don't like sex
what I came to learn
is that wasn't true but that what what
I'd learned to be sex and what I was
bringing as sex this kind of aggressive
you know whatever
was not yes the language that they spoke
right and I feel like I'm surrounded by
men that need to start seeing sex as a
language because then you can ask
yourself well actually she's speaking
Spanish and I'm speaking English that's
why it's not she doesn't like English
she just doesn't she speaks a different
language yeah I mean yes that's a lot
I'm just dumping that on YouTube no that
resonates so and I'm I'm really glad
that you said this because I think
you're speaking something that is on so
many people's minds or something that
they've just never really put language
to and a big part of my
Awakening if you will and really
addressing that sexual shame is because
I also learned sex from porn at 10 years
old 10 years old so by the time that I
had sex for the first time when I was 14
it was very much like a porn performance
to put it very simply and I speak to so
many people men and women about this
very specific thing a lot of us learn
that we should perform that sex should
be driven by orgasm and ejaculation and
this sort of production if you will
which is not actually accurate for most
people when it comes to what really
actually feels pleasurable especially
for women so I started to realize when I
got sober that every time that I was
having sex for example I faked every
single orgasm it was all a perform I
didn't know much about my body because
I'd learned from porn and because the
men that I was with had also learned
from porn we were just in a performance
and no one's actually talking about it
right so in time times when I was in
relationships and I made myself think I
don't want to have sex I don't want to
have sex anymore it actually was not
that I didn't want to have this type of
pornified sex that's what I actually
meant so what you just said is really
important and I realized that's when I
found tantric sex actually yeah that's
when I found tantric sex around 2018
because I realized that I had always
felt like sex was being done to me yes
that I was not a part of it and that is
how most women feel I I felt like I
needed to apologize
yeah because that's what that's what I
came to learn yeah was that the the
reason why the person I was with had
turned around to me and said I don't
like having sex is and when we got
talking about it after I acted like I
mean let me be clear the first time she
said that I did not understand my little
Neanderthal monkey brain went uh like I
was emasculated by it yeah it made me
feel what is this something that I was I
didn't know of course ended up breaking
up but this person got back with this
person a year later
when I was maybe a bit more mature I
apologized and I said I want to have a
conversation and I also said to her that
I'm going to be here regardless of
whether we have sex or not yes and then
she could she had a safe enough space to
start talking to me about it and what I
discovered is she'd been with
should I add three previous boyfriends
over the course of seven years
her view of sex was this person comes
and takes from you treats you like this
object and he was with him for five
years treats you like an object takes
what they want from you and then he was
actually going and cheating on her as
well right so Not only was he taking he
was then like hurting her and that cycle
just repeated her relationship with what
sex is was really really toxic she
didn't like that yes she didn't want
that anymore yes and that's what she and
me probably referred to as this word sex
so it was kind of like learning a new
language of sex and what it actually is
she went from the place of like I don't
have sex anymore
to absolutely loving to have sex yeah I
didn't think it was possible I thought
if they don't like sex dump them yes you
know I'm gonna go find someone else
right that will let me take yes and you
know what you you've articulated that so
beautifully in terms of
sex being a language and it's going to
look different for every single person
because something that I realized is
that I could tell when I was with a man
sexually I could tell if they were sort
of
if it was like a script almost like a
play-by-play like this is exactly the
method we do this we do that switch into
this switch into that it wasn't sort of
flowing and very intuitive as to what's
actually needed in that moment which
reminded me of porn and I would also
realize actually and this is something
that I've spoken about so much because I
ended up um starting a sexual wellness
company called Cherry Revolution over
time
and I realized that even some of the
positions I would get in
were very much like porn because certain
positions in porn are like that because
the camera is there not because it's
comfortable because that's the shot for
the viewer to be able to see it so when
I started to see that I'm starting to
replicate this in my most intimate
private moments but we're both doing it
I made myself believe that I didn't
enjoy sex so then drinking and drugs and
everything that came with it I felt like
those were the moments that I could be
fully expressive without needing to
perform which is very interesting
because you would think it would be the
opposite that I would then perform more
but I felt as if I could actually speak
my mind if I didn't enjoy something can
we try this can I do this instead or I
just want to give or I just want to
receive can we be slower and then when I
was sober I felt like I couldn't say
those things because if I say to you as
my partner I might be emasculating you I
might be embarrassing you you might
think something is wrong so I would just
perform and you're performing as well
and then it just causes a huge
disconnect so tantric sex was the first
thing that I came across that made me
realize and really articulated that sex
is actually not a specific destination
did you know that you can actually enjoy
sex without uh ejaculation that you can
have a full body orgasm that you can be
very slow that foreplay can be the main
thing that you do that you can
experience orgasm without penetration
just so many different ways of
articulating that experience of sex and
it's just that an experience
and that changed so much for me it's
such a sort of a narrative violation for
so many people who've spent their whole
life watching porn and then yeah
recreating it this idea that you can
have an orgasm from touch
that you can use energy to to cause
someone yeah orgasmic pleasure and yeah
um
yeah I do that's it's a really important
topic that I think people need to talk
about a lot more and I think just just
saying to someone that's listening to
this that might be in a relationship
where they're not they're in a sexless
relationship yes just proposing the idea
that what if you both just speak there's
just say there was ten languages what if
you're just speaking the wrong language
right you know what I mean and what
approach would you then take you'd
probably try and learn the language yes
yes and also communicate to them what
language you speak and see and see how
you can be bilingual I guess yeah you
know what it it reminds me of um are you
familiar with Love Languages and and
that that whole thing yes I realized
that a lot of people
expect someone to give in the way that
they like to receive you know so no one
really says okay how do you like to
receive love how do you like to give
love and the moment that I started
asking those questions even though I
believe I [ __ ] cringed in the
beginning I'm like really if I get it
but you get used to it yeah and if they
run off
it's Stephen it's been a game changer to
just ask the person that I'm dating or
my current partner to be like how do you
like to be loved how do you like to
receive love and how do you like to give
it
um because just those simple questions
can change so much and then you can use
the same with sex what do you like and
what do you not like what have you
changed your mind about what do you like
to do now and again or maybe not so much
sometimes
um how much time do you need how does
your arousal actually work and I know
that some people might not know how to
answer these questions for themselves so
it's actually very good to start asking
yourself those questions before was
speaking about it with someone else
these are questions that you can just
start to ask yourself before introducing
them to someone else but they can they
can change so much because I think we
get into relationships and make so many
assumptions based on our individual
experiences and our world view and we
expect the person we're with to reflect
the exact same thing back to us but we
don't we don't ask questions
it comes back in many respects what we
were talking about earlier this kind of
binary approach to life they either fit
or they don't uh-huh there's no space
for conversation and nuance and and and
I guess
um Mutual development together like
towards the same this idea that you have
to actually build and develop a
relationship towards a place of
um satisfaction as opposed to finding
your perfect soul mate or perfect fit
right I'm gonna find someone that likes
to have sex like I do that likes to talk
like I do that likes the things I do as
opposed to this kind of molding towards
being more cohesive together I love that
term Mutual development and it makes me
think actually that this is a term
that can apply even outside maybe even
especially outside of romantic
relationships this idea that people
don't have to be perfect that they don't
have to exist in the way that I want the
world to be or in how I expect them to
be maybe we can actually mutually
develop a different perspective together
because we're two different beings
coming together
my most successful relationship my
current relationship we are completely
different really we don't believe the
same things we don't believe the same
we don't have the same fundamental
beliefs yeah
the reason why it works is because of
one very simple thing
communication a very healthy high
respect communication yeah where
everything isn't an attempt to win it's
an attempt to like genuinely understand
to move forward yeah and I think you can
have two people that are that went very
very different things whether it's in
sex or in business or their beliefs
about religion and spirituality be bound
together as long as they have respectful
communication I agree you know what I
mean I guess empathy is part of
respective education yeah this is a bit
of a left field question but it just
came into my head yeah because I
remember a previous guest writing this
in the diary after they left
very left field
what is the pain that you enjoy having
oh
I won't give my x-rated answer let me
think of
what is
um
I experience a lot of growing pains now
more than ever
now as my especially in the past I would
say four years as the work that I do in
the world reaches more people and as I'm
I'm constantly stretched in a lot of
ways which I really do enjoy but it
challenges my sense of self I think
sometimes it can feel
painful to shed aspects of my identity
and I actually enjoy that I enjoy that
because it is part of my growth process
and this is not a PR answer or anything
like it's the absolute truth I
experience there's the discomfort that I
experienced but sometimes it's painful
because it means that I have to make
decisions that scare me it means that I
have to allow myself to be fully seen
and really step into that idea of being
visible
um and with a with visibility comes a
lot of vulnerability as well so I think
that is a pain that I enjoy and will
gladly accept and then the x-rated thing
that I will not say that's that's the
thing no no this one I'll keep to myself
thank you we just want to monetize this
episode
can I can I turn the question back onto
you of course you can
what is the pain that you enjoy the gym
now I'm joking
no um the first answer that came to mind
quite honestly was heartbreak and I tell
you why because
heartbreak feels like the most intense
pain that I think I've ever experienced
the most all-consuming
um like black hole that I've ever been
in is just like having my heart broken
but at the same time
that pain for me is evidence of so much
it's evidence of my ability to feel so
deeply and so I almost feel sorry for
people that never get to have a
heartbreak because you never get to feel
the full what I think to be the full
spectrum of your heart so it's not
something that I would ever wish for but
it's something that is a real indicator
that I had a chance to feel so strongly
a bit of a weird answer but no no no not
at all
not at all thank you
I am so excited to announce our new
sponsor for this podcast and that is
Blue Jeans by Verizon for any of you
that aren't already familiar with blue
jeans they are a video conferencing and
collaboration tool who offer an
immersive communication experience that
drives pretty unparalleled employee and
customer engagement experiences me and
all of my teams across all of my
portfolio companies switched over to
Blue Jeans a couple of months ago and we
have not looked back the best thing for
us has been the totally frictionless
experience no glitching no sound issues
no delays or any of those things that
usually make virtual meetings really
really frustrating we use blue jeans
anywhere on any device at any time and
it's perfect for my small businesses
that just have 10 or 20 people to some
of my bigger businesses that have
hundreds of people I'm a big fan as you
can probably tell so I've been quite
excited for for some time to announce
this partnership and in the coming weeks
I'll explain the features and really why
it's perfect for you if you haven't
considered using or switching over to
Blue Jeans yeah but if you can't wait
head over to Blue dot com to learn more
honestly it's been one of the real sort
of game changers in my business
what ideas or beliefs do you hold to be
true that pretty much everyone else
disagrees with
things that you are sure are true yeah
but most people I'll tell you one of the
biggest ones that uh
most people didn't like a couple of
years ago when I said um
that is a black person I'm not oppressed
and I mean you could say that anywhere
else in the world and it'll be like yeah
of course we we understand but people
maybe a small minority but a very loud
minority especially at that time where
everything was so overly politicized
really didn't like me saying that as a
black person here in the Western World
having have come from Zimbabwe a country
that is
the population is genuinely truly
oppressed and I know what that looks
like I'm I'm not oppressed I'm not
oppressed because of my race I don't see
my race as a burden yes there are things
that I've experienced a lot of adversity
that I've experienced I know the reality
of what it means to live under the
systems that a lot of us do in and out
of the western world I acknowledge all
of that and at the same time I'm not
oppressed as a woman I'm not oppressed
yes there are oppressive systems and
things that absolutely have to be
questioned and looked at and there are
many things that I advocate for where
people are truly oppressed FGM is an
example I'm a huge advocate for working
with survivors of FGM female genital
mutilation so I work with a lot of
groceries activists I do a lot of work
around that so I understand what
oppression looks like sex-based
oppression but for me as a woman I as an
individual am not oppressed
um
and I think a lot of people didn't
like me saying that but for some reason
because
I think some people saw it as me
undermining
black people or undermining women
which is very odd you know to to even
think about so I think that's something
that is to me completely
non-controversial that was seen as a
controversial statement to make maybe
because of the climate at the time
but that's one of the things that I can
think of that's a decision you're making
it's a decision you're making not to
feel not to label and stick it on your
chest again yes I'm an oppressed person
yeah why are you making that decision
I think
not I think I I know why I wasn't raised
to see myself as a victim I I just
wasn't culturally or in my family home
or with everything that my family and I
or I as an individual have been through
I have never for one second apart from
the moments where I needed to misplace
my own anger and outrage and blame onto
other people around me I never saw
myself as a victim to the world so I
think for me it's not even a conscious
decision that I have to be like okay um
it just is I I don't see myself in that
way I don't walk through the world
thinking that my skin color is a burden
I know that there are things that I
might experience because of it I'm very
aware of that I don't ignore that but I
don't see that as the only truth or the
only side of the coin so it's always
been quite easy for me to say that and a
few years ago I did I never would have
had to declare anything like that at all
but I think something happened
especially in the past two years where
to even
sort of see yourself as a powerful
individual
means that you're taking away from other
people yeah which is not truerto I've
just never seen myself as a victim ever
ever and I won't I won't do it why not
there's a real cost to that just like we
were talking about before there's a
mental emotional spiritual cost to that
and I I just won't [ __ ] do it
um and I think it's a lie it's a lie to
make myself believe that I'm a victim
and that I'm oppressed and I I you know
I'm a powerless individual I'm not I'm
not
are you
no I'm not I can tell yeah yeah that's
why you know it's I get asked this
question a lot when I do talks is about
you know discrimination Steve obviously
you know being a guy a man that was born
in Africa I've got a black mother I'm
I'm I guess I don't know what the
politically correct term is so I'll say
the more mixed race Brown well I don't
know what the correct term is so forgive
me uh half cast I don't know Brown okay
yeah Brown I think you are
um did you not experience discrimination
in business I get this question a lot
and to me it's it's a fascinating
question because my brain goes I don't
care yeah because I can't control it
anyway yeah even if it were I'm sure
it's true I'm sure there's multiple
moments in the rise of my career when I
went into boardrooms and everyone there
was four times my age and white I'm sure
there was
um prejudices before I even opened my
mouth yeah that acted for and probably
against me the thing is I can do nothing
about them in terms of in that moment
and in my my day-to-day life I can't I
can't cure your Prejudice or
discrimination and I don't think it's my
responsibility to right I see my
responsibility as like doing the best
that I can with where I am and with what
I have
and I then heard about this thing called
labeling Theory where in Psychology if
you're given a label it then has a big
impact on your future performance so yes
if I call myself
um if I label myself as oppressed or at
a disadvantage I will start acting like
I'm a disadvantaged person I'll show up
with less confidence with more pessimism
and um and all of those things are
probably going to be more harmful than
the Discrimination itself absolutely so
it was a it was it was a decision that
like to focus on what I can control on a
on a macro level of course you fight
every opportunity you have for equality
and to end systemic discrimination and
to educate people better yeah from a
very early age and to change the way
that media looks and to have more black
podcasters as we've done a big campaign
around and all of those things but on a
day-to-day do I want to burden myself as
you say with um a label which I don't
think will help will serve me right will
help me show up better the answer is
unfortunate is no and that is my
personal decision and yeah others can do
with their life what they wish to yeah
um but I don't think it will serve me
and you can again this goes back to
holding two truths you can you can
choose not to be oppressed but then also
fight for those that 100 will fight for
equality at the same time absolutely
it's not to diminish the authenticity of
the issue
um no and I I also another reason why
I'm very Fierce about this um
is because I think as we have those
conversations around representation Etc
I think we do need to see more people
whether it's black brown what have you
people that are in the minority
depending on where they are
um I think we need to see them
positioned as powerful Sovereign beings
so the reason I'm very serious about the
conversations I have and saying no I'm
not oppressed I do know what oppression
looks like and I will continue to
Champion for as you say equality Etc but
I it it's actually my responsibility to
claim my power as an individual who
inhabits a black body it's actually my
responsibility this has to be a part of
the representation conversation we can't
always just want black people to step
forward to talk about the struggle
because just like you say I started to
notice actually that
every panel that I would get invited to
do all the interviews
it would start with something along the
lines of so Africa as a black woman yeah
South Africa as a woman of color what
have you experienced nothing what if I
haven't experienced any kind of what if
I don't have some kind of story because
I started to find that it would put me
into a position where I would kind of
feel like I have to find a story where
something but what if nothing happened
you know why can't I just be seen as a
writer as a consultant as a business
owner as an entrepreneur without being a
black entrepreneur or a black speaker or
all of which I really value and I see
the importance in recognizing those
things in those specific terms but why
does it have to be positioned in such a
way where I have to look for adversity
connected to my race so I've really
started to be very firm around that and
to reject that and in in interviews to
say I'm really curious to know why you
opened the question like that
you know and sometimes people don't even
realize they're doing it because they've
it's just become a script you know that
would be a terrifying rebuttal if I if
I'd asked you that I was and I was not
in a minority
right I'd be terrified because you're
right there's there's almost this
assumption that you're going to be the
voice of Oppression on this battle so
we're gonna come to the yeah depressed
now and we're going to ask you about
oppression right so I think there's a
bit of cognitive distance where then
someone like me says actually no I'm not
oppressed people don't kind of know what
to do with you then it is really yeah
Violet's a bunch of narratives right and
that's a good thing
Who You Are
no Africa you are but you and don't
forget that and be but Stephen that
happens yeah I know that happens in some
messages that you get how how can I deny
how can you deny that you're oppressed
I've had people tell me
um
so that's very interesting because it
tends to be white people a lot of the
time that do that
because they they kind of and in a way I
sort of can understand where they're
coming from and that they really want to
stand up for something they really
believe
um
this idea that every single person that
fits into this identity Market thinks
and behaves and has had this experience
so they don't then realize that they've
become quite regressive in their quest
to be Progressive which is very it's
very interesting
I had the most interesting conversation
um about racism on Twitter many years
ago where
um
I think the I think the trending topic
of the day was like you can't speak you
can't tell a black person what racism is
or something like that and so and I'm
saying well no like racism can go both
ways I I can be racist to a white person
yes I can be I can not give someone a
job because they're white I can
discriminate against them purely based
on their skin color I can be and this
one this this lady online was arguing
with me basically saying no white people
can't tell a black person what racism is
she was saying that to me and I
literally you're telling me
what racism is right now yeah and that
is totally okay yes and she apologized
she went you're completely right I
should never have spoken she literally
went I should never have told you what
racism is she got herself caught in her
own right because she abandoned truth
and she just started falling in line
with this like yeah binary nonsense
narrative that white people can't talk
about races yeah what are you [ __ ]
talking about yes
to be honest as well like I'm half white
right
I've got this luxury I can shape-shift
so yeah so does that mean because I'm
half white I can only half talk about
racism right because it's also racist
just to say that I'm black that's just
picking one half of my identity right so
see how this entire thing falls apart
the more that you sort of you
interrogate interrogate anyway you
blowing it it just [ __ ] crumbles
because it's just [ __ ] it's propped
up [ __ ] by people that are virtually
signaling right just don't know what
they think or believe so they've just
gone with the cult it's like yeah it's
the script it's the script that's why I
think um questioning
and it can seem so simple but
questioning can really allow you to sort
of snap out of this trance because a lot
of it is it's a trance it's a script
that people repeat and you regurgitate
that interrogation right it's like you
wake up in the morning you go to your
like your side and then they give you
the the beliefs the 174 beliefs that you
have to believe and you go okay cool got
it and you you don't even look at it you
just insert it in your little it's like
a SIM card they just put it in your
brain and you never understand why you
believe these things because they're not
your beliefs yeah someone said to me one
day they said um if you if you believe
the same things as everybody around you
they're not your beliefs and it was a
really interesting thing because it's
true that's powerful but think if you
believe every if you believe pretty much
everything that everyone around you
believes they are not to your beliefs
they're the beliefs of the society you
lived in if I moved you to
Germany at a certain time you might well
have had a different set of beliefs
exactly you know what I mean yes or if I
moved you back to the you know in my
history's Goods the 16th century when
slavery was Rife yes and you you had a
slave you might have believed it
completely different set of things but
okay and normal so beliefs there's
there's very little correctness to it to
many of them
if happiness is this recipe that
contains all of these essential
ingredients in order for you to make the
the dish of happiness
what is your
recipe
which ingredients are you currently
lacking for that recipe
which ingredients am I lacking for the
recipe of happiness
you said that much clearer than I did I
should just use that
just before we take that when she's gone
no question
um
vulnerability
yeah really really I would surprise a
lot of people yeah and it's tied to what
I mentioned around romantic
relationships
yeah
allowing myself to be more vulnerable
I think that could
allow me to have access to layers of
happiness that I haven't yet experienced
that's what comes to mind but it's a
it's a it feels like a very big question
because I think it makes you well it
makes me have to think about even just
with the word luck it makes me have to
sort of turn
that mirror onto myself
um
yeah but I think honestly I'm able to be
vulnerable in so many other areas but if
I think about the happiness that I could
experience in terms of romance
vulnerability
it's funny when you think it when you're
answering that question I was thinking
about the analogy of ingredients and one
of the things that
um makes a recipe go bad isn't a lack of
ingredients it's the wrong quantities
yes which is probably what people call
balance yes if I put a fourth egg in
when it says three eggs the recipe goes
bad right so as I think about that in
terms of balance you think about the
scales of ingredients that you're
weighing up you've got to get the right
quantities of each ingredient in order
to make a great recipe sometimes I think
in my case I maybe have too much of I
have too many eggs yeah you know what I
mean too many eggs in the basket I have
too much professional commitments and
I've I've I don't have enough sugar
which is maybe romance and that kind of
connection yes so maybe one can have all
the ingredients there but just have the
complete wrong quantities yes to ruin
the
the recipe that's a good one we have a
closing tradition on this podcast where
the last guest writes a question for the
next guest
what is the crazy
big
idea
you would try
if you knew you could not fail
I want to start off first of all or a
huge annual event that is a place for
all of us to express our Unthinkable
thoughts
and
it's going to be a place for people to
come and see what honest raw and
filtered respectful compassionate
communication looks like in real time
and
I want this to become something that is
global I want it to become
something that has a life of its own
outside of me
and
I've wanted to do this for a very very
long time
um and I know that I'd be able to do it
very well
but I think it's it feels scary because
I know that I could do it very well
yeah and I've never shared that out loud
um I'm not sure if I understand that
last part it was still scary because I
know I can do it yeah that doesn't make
a lot of sense to me it does really yeah
and I'll tell you what I mean by that
it's almost like that feeling that I was
telling you off when I would get emails
and offers to speak for half an hour
which comes so easily to me and get paid
so much money
so I would resist it because I know
that I can do it and I know that I'm
going to get rewarded so much from it
which means that there's a leap in
identity that has to happen which feels
quite scary so it's almost the same with
this event and this idea that I have and
it's it seems as you say like it doesn't
make sense it's scary because you know
that it's going to succeed it's scary
because you know that it's going to work
um and something that I've had to work
on over time is the fear of success
yeah
so this event and this thing that I want
to do is sort of linked to that it's a
barrier that I have to
break and will
um so yeah what a great question
Africa thank you
um I wanted to speak to you because I
saw so much so much nuance and truth and
um importance in the way that you
communicate but also watch you
communicate and so it's very rare these
days that I will DM someone out of the
blue and say you should come on my
podcast yeah and that is just a for me
that is a
um a sign of how much I respect what
you're doing and how important I think
it is to have conversations that are you
know there are Unthinkable thoughts and
that are fearless and that are um
challenging whether they are right or
whether they are wrong I'm a big
believer in just being able to have the
conversation because I think that is the
starting point of progress where you can
where two ideas can Clash and then they
can merge and find the truth and move
forward as maybe one shared idea um and
there's not enough of that there's not
enough people like you that are doing
that so you I have a suspicion I have a
very big suspicion that you are going to
be a very important voice
on a global level and that you are going
to be a star I really believe that
because
you're very rare and it's an important
rare it's a very important round it's a
it's a hopefully it's a flourishing type
of rare but it's it feels like it's
become a bit of a Dying Breed of rare
and people that are willing to have
conversations
um regardless of
how they might be perceived right by
those that receive those those
conversations so thank you for being
that voice in society and I think this
is just the start of our friendship if I
feel that might make you cringe because
yeah
friendship please more of them we are
best friends yeah let's say okay we'll
revisit that yeah we'll get back Stephen
thank you um you know what I was saying
to my friend Emily that I
was really just looking forward to this
conversation because
especially in the time where everything
is so heavily politicized and people are
sort of lead with identity and what it
means to be a certain person I think I
was just really looking forward to
having this conversation with you
because of the work that you do beyond
the work in itself your curiosity and
your willingness to sort of learn and to
be open and to change your mind and to
be corrected and to also be assertive
but to also be soft and to just allow
for ideas to exist openly without
disagreeing or agreeing just hearing I
think it's yeah I think it is you know
something that is quite rare but I think
through conversations like this it
actually causes a beautiful ripple
effect so
I I do think this is the start of a
friendship so thank you thank you
I had a few words to say about one of my
sponsors on this podcast for many years
people have been asking for a coffee
flavored Hill and quite recently he'll
release the iced coffee caramel flavor
of their um ready to drink Hills and
I've just become hooked on it over the
last couple of weeks I've been on a
really interesting Journey with huel
which I've described and talked about a
little bit on this podcast I started
with the berry ready to drinks then I
moved over to the protein salted caramel
because it's 100 calories and it gives
you all of your essential vitamins and
minerals but also gives you the 20 odd
grams of protein you need and now I'm
balanced between them both I drink
mostly the banana flavor ready to drink
I've got really into the iced coffee
caramel flavor of Jules ready to drink
and now I'm drinking that as well as the
protein make sure you try the new ready
to drink flavors that the caramel flavor
is amazing the new banana flavor as well
is amazing and obviously as I said the
iced coffee caramel flavor has been a
real Smash Hit
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]